a pesar del fallo del juez del circuito
federal de australia anthony que al y
que le devolvió a novak djokovic la
libertad y la posibilidad de disputar el
abierto de tenis el ministro federal de
inmigración álex todavía tiene el poder
legal de cancelar su visa y deportarlo
también puede prohibirle la entrada
australia hasta por tres años el
gobierno informó que está analizando el
proceso los ojos de la opinión pública
ahora están puestos en los documentos
radicados por la defensa de djokovic
ante la corte y en la veracidad de la
información entregada por el tenista
pues mentir en formularios oficiales es
una de las causales que le permiten al
ministro cancelar su visa de forma
definitiva en las últimas horas han
surgido cuestionamientos sobre el
formulario de salud que todos los
viajeros del exterior deben diligenciar
para entrar en la pregunta de si ha
viajado o planea viajar en los 14 días
previos a su viaje a australia djokovic
respondió que no varias publicaciones en
redes sociales que están siendo
analizadas presuntamente evidenciarían
que el tenista durante esos 14 días
habría estado no solo en españa desde
donde salió su vuelo sino que también en
serbia su país natal
mientras tanto novak djokovic ha podido
en la cancha del voleibol harina
escenario número 1 del torneo a través
de un comunicado la asociación de
tenistas profesionales le pidió a la
organización tenis australia claridad en
los procedimientos de ingreso al país y
reveló que el 97 por ciento de los tops
jan que van a jugar el torneo tienen la
vacuna por ahora el futuro de djokovic
es incierto el torneo empieza el próximo
lunes pero todavía no se ha dicho la
última palabra